Vsauce Kevin here with a slot car race
track to visualize how fast I can safely
drive without getting pulled over
what's my maximum speed without wreaking
havoc on the justice system and how can
we use game theory to find the answer
here we go all right that didn't really
work out very well honestly I don't even
have enough room to properly set up this
track on this table so I'm gonna need
some help
luckily I partnered with curiosity
stream and I know just the guy hey Sean
as hosts of the awesome new curiosity
stream show speed I was hoping that you
could help me visualize speeding what
looks like you already have
yeah well that track here Kevin to do
just that I have magically manifested
exactly the same track that you had
right here on my favorite convene yeah
boom okay so let's race I will be the
cop car and you will be the civilian
driver I wouldn't have it any other way
okay do I get a head start yes I'm gonna
pull you over let's go let's go okay so
I'm racing ahead yeah there's a turbo
button if she can use coming in the
straightaway that's helping to gain on
you actually yeah
but turbo in the corner it's too much
speed and you're fly right off why did
that happen though okay that happens
because in this case you over seeded the
coefficient of friction between the
tires and the slot and the top of the
track now these cars they can go around
the corner a lot faster than a normal
car can because they have this little
peg that's riding in that slot yeah so
when they go around the corner they're
resisting centripetal force which wants
to swing it off but what the car wants
to keep going in a straight line right
but this slot helps drag it around the
corner now in our cars we don't have a
slot so if we go around a corner too
fast we slide off when we exceed the
coefficient of friction of our tires and
our tires oh they look kind of big they
really don't have that much space on the
road I'm going to show you that I
brought one of the tires off one of my
motorbikes here I'm just gonna sharpie
the top here this looks like a pretty
big around tire all right
rides down the road only when it's
riding down the road on the street
it's really only got about one inch Wow
all right if we take a look at that
there there's really only about one inch
wide and maybe three inches long that's
the contact between me and the
motorcycle on the ground the same is
true on the tires on your car right the
tire is all the way around but the only
part actually touching the ground if
that little bit on the bottom and if you
have your tires overinflated you're
getting a much smaller contact patch
that makes sense
tires not deforming yeah yeah so that
little bit the contact patch is
important to understand you've got four
of these little contact patches there
maybe four inches by five inches wide on
your four tires and the weight of that
car pushing down on that contact patch
is the only thing that keeps you from
sliding off the road when you go around
a corner the weight of the car Laettner
said the car wants it to go keep going
straight when you turn the car the front
wheels move off in one direction and the
friction makes those tires track around
the corner the reason that's important
is because you're also using that same
friction not only to go around a corner
but you're using it to accelerate into
brake if you accelerate too fast you
overcome the coefficient of friction
between your tires and the ground with
that little contact patch and you do a
burnout mhx lot of fun in a controlled
environment but the more important thing
for all of us driving around that's
really really pertinent to our safety is
that the faster you go you're asking
more and more of that little tiny
contact patch to help slow you down when
you hit the brakes so if you're going
way faster you have to be easier on the
brakes if you lock up the brakes you'll
slide the whole car forward that's
what's happening here is you just have
it carrying too much speed into the turn
tires and the slot can't take it you're
sliding right off the track okay I'll
try it again yeah yeah where's the cop
car let's restore them right okay
so that's a technical reason why you
don't want to speak but there's lots of
other reasons why you don't want to
speak - right yeah I mean that's why
it's dangerous to speed but also in
society you know you have to have oh
there we go in society we can't have
that happen no we can't have that
happening you know we want everyone to
be safe and we have rules and
regulations and law enforcement in place
to make sure that everyone is acting
safely the thing we don't really think
about is that driving in a system
governed by law enforcement is actually
a two-player game and both the driver
and the police officer are playing this
game let's say that the speed limit is
65 miles per hour what's the fastest
that you've ever driven because I have a
feeling it's a lot more than that I've
driven about 130 miles now okay yeah but
my question is what is a sensible speed
to drive on the highway the answer that
question is somewhat complicated cuz it
really depends on the highway and the
conditions and if it's raining and the
state of your car right but in general
for for roads that are we collectively
deemed we need to go slower in because
either it's near neighborhood or because
the road itself is twistier we have the
lower speed limits yeah and then we have
big straight super highways where we can
all do 75 or whatever the limit is in
your in your area but the point is that
cops can't pull over every single driver
just for going one mile per hour over
whatever that limit is because not only
is that logistically impossible but that
level of law enforcement would probably
make everyone pretty angry so when we
drive and the police monitor us were
playing a game of recursion to get the
best result both of the police and the
drivers are sort of playing this game
from different sides exactly exactly
we've got a couple of basic rules in
this game we have a legal speed limit of
let's say 65 miles per hour and we have
common sense rules that tell us that we
can only go so fast before it gets
dangerous and we're flying off the edge
of the road and the police officer has a
threshold at which he or she will ticket
the driver so each player is deciding
what to do
based on what they think the other
player will do yeah there's a gray area
isn't there yeah yeah it basically works
like this as the cop I'm thinking how
fast does Sean think that he can go
without getting pulled over right and as
the driver I'm thinking how fast can I
get away with without getting pulled
over exactly exactly and as the cop I'm
also thinking how fast is Sean think I
think he thinks he can go and he's
thinking how fast do I think he thinks
he can go and that's recursion at the
end of this process which can be
infinite both the driver and the cop
decide their best courses of action for
the driver that's like you said how fast
he can go safely without getting a
ticket and for the cop that's how fast
he'll let the driver go before pulling
them over and this whole game takes
place in that gray area I mean I know if
I stay under 65 on that we can pulled
over that's the easy way to do it right
and I know if I go 130 I'm gonna get
pulled over so there's this strip there
and that's the gray area where that that
game you're talking about is getting
played ultimately so what do you think
would be an exact value if the limit was
65 miles per hour that we could get like
you could drive without getting pulled
over and so that you're happy with the
speed that you're going I think it's
general wisdom that you can get away
with about five miles over the speed
limit especially on the highway when
there's no chance of coming across the
stop sign or someone on the road right
so when there's in a safe environment
like that I think everybody pretty much
feels like they can go five miles over
the speed limit and not get pulled over
or somewhere in that gray area both of
the police and speeder for playing this
game from their own sides right the
speeder trying to figure out how fast
they can get away with the police trying
to figure out how much they'll allow but
they both have an incentive to make the
whole system work so when they both play
the game and they find this place where
they get to speed a little and don't get
pulled over there it's in that gray area
they find a balance and that balance is
called a Nash
equilibrium what Sean described is the
best reply to another player's best
action and when neither player has an
incentive to deviate from their decision
they've reached a Nash equilibrium okay
I need to talk more about Nash
equilibrium but I need my whiteboard
table so thank you so much Sean for all
of your help make sure that you watch
his show speed on curiosity stream I
know that you guys will love it but for
now I have to I have to I have to go
okay now one of the most famous Nash
equilibrium scenarios comes in the form
of the well-known prisoner's dilemma the
scene is simple two people get arrested
for a crime they're separated and can't
communicate with each other the police
can convict both on a lesser charge but
they need more proof to convict them on
the big one that means one has to
testify that the other did the crime so
is it in each prisoner's best interest
to rat on the other one or to stay quiet
here's how it plays out if both
prisoners a and B rat on each other
they'll each get two years in prison if
a blames B but B stays quiet a goes free
and B gets three years in prison and
vice versa if both a and B stay quiet
they'll each get one year in prison the
rational prisoner rats because that's
the only way he's going to go free and
when he rats it always gives him a
better result than if he doesn't rat
regardless of what the other prisoner
does that's called a dominant strategy
and the Nash equilibrium in the
prisoner's dilemma is achieved by
betrayal but if the other prisoner also
behaves rationally he would rat as well
and they'd both get two years the best
course of action here is cooperation
where both stay quiet serve a lesser
sentence and have the least bad outcome
in the prisoner's dilemma not betraying
the other guy goes against the Nash
equilibrium but it gives the best
possible result for both players
mind because if one rats and the other
doesn't three years are served and if
they both rat four years are served
through cooperation only two years are
served political scientist Robert
Axelrod asked 14 game theory experts to
submit computer simulations of the
prisoner's dilemma the ones that
advocated more self-interest by betrayal
were noted as not nice players while the
ones that focused on cooperation they
were nice after running them all the top
half of the performers were all nice
models while the bottom half were all
not nice so it pays to be nice as long
as the other player thinks it pays to be
nice too we play these two-player games
all day long not just with the police
when we give a gift were playing a game
for example say you've just met someone
and you kind of like them giving them a
spatula is probably not a great gift
giving them a diamond ring on the second
date is probably a bit much
pump the brakes there Billy in the gift
giving game you want to send the right
message based on what you feel and the
recursive process that happens with what
you think they'll feel you want to feel
good about the gift you gave and they
want to feel good about the gift they
received and whether you're driving down
the highway or trying to impress your
crush you're almost always in some kind
of two-player game and sometimes you're
in several at once the best way to play
is to be smart to pay attention and keep
your best interest in mind
but you'll usually win the most when you
make sure to be nice
I guess grandma was right and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
hey gigantic thanks to Sean Riley for
opening up his shop to me go check out
his brand-new show speed it's a
four-part DocuSign blasts through
humanity's Need for Speed on land Wow
on sea through the skies and into space
curiosity stream and I worked out a deal
for you so that you can sign up and get
30 days completely free just click the
link below and go to curiosity stream
comm slash Vsauce 2 and enter the promo
code
Vsauce - all lowercase curiosity stream
gives you unlimited access to over 2400
brain feeding documentaries starting at
just $2.99 per month but for you you can
watch Sean's show free by using the
promo code Vsauce - so you should do
that the show is awesome honestly you'll
like it go watch it go watch it now ok
now